sin ninguna duda tenemos un problema en
la región en américa latina somos en la
región
y anteúltima en acceder a las vacunas la
última está siendo áfrica
y esto comparación no es una simple
comparación sino es la realidad de que
la ciencia las más de 600 millones de
personas en latinoamérica para lograr su
inmunidad de rebaño tiene que lograr el
70 por ciento de la vacunación y lo que
es importante es que esa vacunación se
accederá rápidamente debido a que las
variantes que están circulando en el
mundo ya en algunos países de
latinoamérica está circulando y la mitad
de latinoamérica va a entrar en las
próximas seis semanas en una nueva
temporada en otoño y por lo tanto
estamos por enfrente una probabilidad de
una segunda o tercera ola por lo tanto
tenemos la necesidad de la región de
acceder a cientos de millones de dosis
en los próximos en los próximos 8 a 12
de semana y esto no está pasando sólo
está pasando en algunos países donde
empiezan a recibir dosis como es el
ejemplo
en el cual había generado investigación
durante el año pasado pasé tres en
muchas de esas vacunas acuerdos con las
universidades y por lo tanto acuerdo
también en la recibir las vacunas y
demostraban que serán vacunas eficaces y
seguras ahora está chile adelante porque
está recibiendo ya la vacuna es el
cronograma de entrega y logrando alta
tasa de vacunación que no es lo que pasa
en el resto de la región doctor
viendo este panorama que usted década
decide entonces cuál es el principal
problema en nuestra región para que la
vacunación masiva no esté siendo
efectiva en el grueso de américa latina
no disponer de vacunas pero la
disposición de vacunas no está en el
problema de la producción sólo mundial
sino en el problema que tuvieron los
países en no realizar acuerdos tempranos
para que sea lo cada producto sea lo
cara vacunas y entonces de esa manera
llegar a la vacuna soy por ejemplo en la
iniciativa kóvacs está que es una
iniciativa que quiere lograr que por
ejemplo en la región
a los 36 36 países lleguen a una tasa de
vacunación del 10 por ciento con un
primer paso de llegar al 3 o 4 por
ciento recibiendo las dosis pero todavía
no están llegando estas vacunas a través
de kóvacs se piensa que va a ser en las
próximas semanas y después los países va
a depender su arriba de vacuna y su tasa
de evaporación depende de los acuerdos
que haya realizado algunos han hecho
acuerdos con un solo país o con un solo
proveedor de vacuna o con dos o tres y
van a tener por supuesto el éxito del
control basado fundamentalmente en estos
acuerdos y en el cronograma que entrega
de que tengan de entrega de vacunas muy
muy rápidamente autor inmune ar de baño
la podemos lograr más o menos para
cuando no en la región no se va a lograr
la inmunidad de rebaño de este año
imagínense la vez que tenemos que
vacunar más de 47
más de 400 millones de personas si no
tenemos la disponibilidad ni la
logística no sería un problema que va a
tener la disponibilidad de las 400
millones de vacunas antes de fin de año
por lo tanto de manera español este año
en la región no se piensa que se va a
lograr rápidamente